[Musique]
oh
marmaille comme on l'était ont été
attirés par le mouvement
l'expression corporelle et lala me vois
déjà la bruce lee par exemple wahaha par
exemple mais moi c'est tout le monde a
fait mal abeilles là dans ma grande isle
adam était imprégné de ça après lui hop
là il y aura entre iam
ouais et puis la russie une tendance
appelée jamaïcaine de ce style que
l'était le raggamuffin et comme pop
music
il emmène avec lui et qu'il tire et la
maja mallet qu'il avait un monsieur tu
appelles marcus garvey marcus garvey
il était dit que un peuple sur culturel
comme un arbre sans racines et la balle
réfléchissent à bien il veut dire si -
mais pratiquer un art qu'il ya
d'amérique une jamaïque quand ça
l'américain et sa pratique le yen
chemin mais revient ici médias - que
forme intéressent à moi mon
environnement culturel musical entre le
maloya maloya dodo d'aussi à la case là
pas moins 8 de dopage et coquin pour le
moins nana son goal est la terre - là
point b commenté la scuderia moins fan
bouteille l'essence dans la cage maloya
les très belles avec lui l'histoire la
mémoire et nout l'espoir qu'en part
à où le hasard c'est l'ombre de dieu
quand l'élève est enfin prêt le maître
arrive
saleh qu'il dit dans le roi lion me
rancourt professeurs de conservatoire de
musique réunionnaise qui appelle
françois matthys taux se bouclait du
moins bien apprendre ça le conservatoire
mais ça va une pratique mais me why we
can a fait 1 1 à philippe locaux mais ça
va aussi
ce cabaret quand william malouda il faut
se donner service kabaré service kabaré
service kabaré cérémonie cérémonie
oussalah n'auront en hommage aux ans est
au défunt nous fait la nourriture
bezotte des offrandes et puis le soir
une danse du chant et de la musique
toubana alors les soirs mon étonnement *
amarré au port d'un site d'un immeuble
appelle la croyance mi dance comme ça
mais à fond dans mon budget élèves non
mais m l'inspiration la transquadra dire
un est là et madame il voit moins
prêtresse de camaret le service et les
diamants faut bien dense dedans
cérémonie aussi un c'est là qu'il fait
moins tilt qu'il prenne en compte la
danse ah tiens faymoreau il continue
puis un jour il rencontre une dame à la
réunion africaine qui enseigne la danse
africaine salamata diallo et 7
cette femme n'est vraiment bon quads
sont transmission sa technique son
énergie où il parle au moins ça y parla
moyens et l'emmène un déclic
la danse maloya il peut être enseignée
mal à analyser la regarder à décortiquer
pas nous ont souvent donné pas il
revient sipa la wako ou encore un jour
me connaissait
ce cabaret newey madame danse carrément
invisible cette dame joue le percussions
se son pied mais l'étonné une autre fois
encore moins une jeune fille en train de
danser que tu te dis que non mais c'est
quoi ça autant de techniques que nous
voit que l'oci riche cette danse là dans
mon observation il dit galina faire mais
ni dire moyens que il faudrait peut-être
donné des noms passés par exemple du
nord au sud sous des piles et il veut
peut être dire peut-être ça il ya
peut-être peut-être ça mais ma mire on a
moins de compte que alors dans ce cas il
faut que dans mon structures
pédagogiques dans mon cours me dis que
ça c'est çà et là me décide de nous
mêler pas avec mon propre initiative
donc ce pas ça va être fini
ok il se passe ça va être rasé ou encore
damien da mais ça tu connais dans les
grands flux là bas en france mme
animatrice 1 dames on va des images
comme ça et bien sûr ceux par qui
pensent devant elle fait penser à un
moment moment un répétons toulouges de
son gaz
tu m laon caustique peinture rouge
il fallait brossé qu'à moitié de coq au
sec une brosse quoi et donc grosse coco
est donc ce pas normal y brosse croco ou
encore nantes
danse comme ça on y voit qu'en monde
s'alarme nage la rivière selon roche
il te regarde si le lait jeté avait la
tâche de sous donc n'appelle salle le
royal avait autant de pas qui est déjà à
retenir
voilà que maintenant nous les prix la
réunion les prêts pour pâtes à son mode
ou transmettent à zot la dance mania dit
des délégués des gays cha cha cha que
d'un gai gai écoute et ding ding ding un
pic à cha cha cha cha cha cha cha cha
cha à tous
des fois vous savoir mon ami heath ou
pellets de bois est souvent loin on
connaît axel l'enracinement fait pousser
ses branches est mon maître et ami c'est
lahoud se
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]